[Music]
this is little ducky engage in the
sixteen but it's embarrassing to be this
age and still start to sweat say use
your laptop for the Internet
this game is called autofill Russian
roulette and there's only three safe
letters in the alphabet oh god please
don't let them typos I repeat or an X or
an R or a tea or a beo on second thought
give that laptop back to me angle the
screen and discreetly click recent
history
[Music]
maybe I don't respect myself Taco Bell
four times a week I don't do this for my
health but I cannot eat at home because
it always makes me nauseous Brita filter
ain't been change since W was still in
office yeah take to the streets we round
them all this doughnuts in the parking
lot weather new so we sit and watch TV
with your tongue wife and dumb baby I'm
out there bombing the city and got a
whole squad with me yeah
squats pretty much just round he speak
English know that good but he still
seems pretty cool he doesn't know it but
he's probably like my closest friend and
he lets me read
[Music]
the TV on
or depressing and but don't think
i'll figure
[Music]
you